so we're living through a psychedelic
revolution
that's happening in parallel to a mental
health epidemic
800 000 people are now dying by suicide
every year according to the world health
organization that's a larger number than
the amount of people that die from
natural disasters and armed conflict
combined so we're at a war
against mental illness and there is this
psychedelic
revolution happening concurrently now
psychedelics have this
capacity seemingly to reset the self
they open up what
robin carthart harris calls pivotal
mental states
which are these unique states of
increased suggestibility
where even the person in the throngs of
the most treatment resistant depression
and anxiety
can all of a sudden be reconstituted so
to speak you might think of these
medicines as medicines that address the
fracturings of the psyche
but again they do this because they open
up this pivotal mental state
of increased suggestibility it's a very
delicate space it's a space in which
which an open heart surgery of the
psyche is literally taking place and so
we should not
kid ourselves there need to be guard
rails there need to be
protocols and procedures you need to
connect people
with psychotherapists with psychedelic
psychotherapists who have been trained
who have been vetted
who are trustworthy who have a moral
compass who are not going to introduce
their own
baggage into the patient when they're in
such a highly suggestible state
so we are in need of a trust network
that
vets psychedelic psychotherapists that
protects
users patients those in the throngs of
mental distress
from being taken advantage of by
charlatans right this is
hugely important so there's a new
company called
psycable and i'm really excited because
what they're doing is precisely that
they're creating a kind of trust network
where we can actually vet psychedelic
psychotherapists what you might call
trip sitters now again there are
psychedelic compounds that are already
legal and are being used in
active psychedelic psychotherapy things
like ketamine
is legal things like cannabis are legal
in many states across the united states
it's legal in canada it was recently
legalized in mexico
compounds like ayahuasca the people fly
to costa rica or brazil
to join these psychedelic ceremonies so
to speak so
whether it's through the the legal
frameworks in america or whether it's
through these gray zones across the
world people are
doing this and so short of giving them
medical advice what we can at the very
least
offer people is the chance to talk to an
expert
you know it's the very chance to the
opportunity to talk to somebody who
knows what they're talking about
who can offer best practices protocols
and procedures harm reduction
potentially and the point is
psycable will create a trust network for
all of this information
to be shared where people can seek out
advice where people can seek out
information
people can educate themselves because
more important than anything i think
is that we create safe spaces for people
to partake in these
visionary journeys you know people who
are in the throngs of mental distress
have suffered enough what we don't want
is for them to walk
into a fire into a burning bush so let's
protect people
let's create a trust network that can
protect people and let's get behind the
folks at psycable because i think
they're doing good work in the world
so check them out if you have a chance
and
thanks for listening